[Music]
dink dink dink can I sit like this the
whole podcast welcome back to the slouch
podcast I hate the gingerly podcast yeah
see however you want it's your podcast
nobody gonna correct your posture you
know but you don't call me someone might
but not me yeah welcome back to the
podcast everybody this episode is
brought to you by post mates the amazing
delivery service for food that you can
eat all your favorite restaurants
delivered to your house I mean what more
can you ask we use it all the time go to
post mates calm well you can oppose many
stocks check it out but really just
download the post mates have used code
gender Julian sorry for the hundred
dollars off free delivery credit for
your first seven days that's our names
Jenna Julian as the code and it will
automatically be applied to your account
then you can start eating it's like
we're dining together almost Thank You
postman's didn't used me all right let's
turn him around it doesn't feel right
when he's just looking at us addressing
welcome to podcast Bob welcome to the
podcast Bob you want to go on some
rapids no creating an environment of
distrust
oh he trusts me so much I know how much
he trusts me
how much last night he followed me up to
bed yes cuz I went to bed a little bit
before you yes I had a little treat for
him yeah he came into bed fed in the
treat he said thank you and then he went
and then he left I know I was gonna say
where's the story going because I
brought him up to bed he left he doesn't
trust me oh he's kissing you oh he's
helping my street cred just use me as a
ladder I'm not a ladder I get roasted
every podcast ver my interactions with
you but we both know that you you know
we're cool right he loves his Papa okay
your tongues very long I'm gonna let you
keep it inside your mouth for now if
that's okay with you we got bunny over
here off camera she's licking up a storm
it sounds like
a monster if you hear any grumbling in
the background it's her licking herself
yeah it's definitely that well anyway we
wanted to play a game today that one of
you guys suggested last week I feel bad
that I don't have their name on the top
of my head but one of you guys in the
comments I believe it was a comments
section comment that had suggested we
play a game where I one of us compiles
real Florida headlines and makes a bunch
of fake Florida headlines and Jenna has
to guess what are what are the real ones
what are the fake ones yeah so we're
gonna play that but we wanted to quickly
talk about some news that came out today
that's actually really massive news I
would say 99% of you probably already
heard of it you don't talk about
something that you know ain't none of
our business but we go and talk about
well it is our business normally we
don't talk about things because they
aren't our business but I would argue
that this is 100% our business because
of how much time we spend streaming on
Twitch and the news was that ninja one
of the most popular the streamers on the
platform of twitch signed an agreement
to exclusively leave twitch and stream
on mixer which for a long time has been
twitches competition I guess no one I
mean no one in our circle or no one I've
ever really met has talked about mixer
as like a I don't know a real competitor
or they are a competitor but they've
never seemed to really give twitch a run
for their money until today today has
been it's big news
ninja moving to mixer and I thought we
would have a little discussion about it
just very bare-bones but pretty much
like this could mean a whole slew of
different things for people who are
streaming on Twitch for people who
haven't yet started streaming but are
considering streaming and now they have
well okay I'm gonna have a second
thought you know am I actually just
going to create a twitch channel or do I
go to mixer there's a lot to break down
a lot of it is is I would say a lot of
its productive to talk about and then
there's a lot of it that's not
productive to talk about like how much
do you get paid or what
why he'd do it you know I think that's
kind of his business but it is super
interesting this this news is big news
it's it's absolutely gonna change things
in some way shape or form for twitch and
the whole scape of live-streaming right
now
it's interesting to me because it's it's
happened in the past on the internet in
different capacities and there's been
different results and I've seen a lot of
people's opinions about ninja moving
some of which are really good I think
there's compelling arguments as to why
it's good and that it creates more
competition which is always a good thing
because what you don't enjoy is having a
monopolize platform which in theory
sometimes YouTube does have and we have
seen big creators from YouTube leave and
we have seen what happens like take for
example vine when all of the top
creators sort of sat down with vine and
we're like you're gonna give us you know
a million or something dollars each or
else we're all even and they all left
and we all know what happened to vine
you know I think it's an interesting
concept when your biggest talent on any
given platform decide that they're going
to take their business elsewhere and
what happens and I don't really have a
theory as to what's gonna happen because
you know the live streaming space is is
different you know there's YouTube and
twitch and D live and mixer and there
has been all kinds of different mobile
live streaming platforms there's you now
you know I think it's interesting that
twitch doesn't in theory have a monopoly
on live streaming but they're very large
and twins our Ninja is obviously very
large so who knows it could mean nothing
or it could be everything we could be
streaming on mixer in two years time or
we could be on twitch like nothing ever
happened
I'd have to look at our contract to see
if that's even possible now I think what
makes this extra interesting is the fact
that microsoft owns mixer so you're not
looking at a competitor who is sort of
like a question mark as to like who's
funding it you know how much do they
have what kind of legs is that company
or platform has
in this race to be number one on live
streaming there's not like that that
question mark because at the end of the
day
Microsoft is Microsoft with a lot of
money and they can keep infusing as far
as I know I might not know anything but
in theory they could keep infusing there
Microsoft's money into mixer which is
what they did today I know I've been
giving my money to Microsoft for years
now for Elder Scrolls for Xbox oh my god
you probably helped pay ninja I probably
did but that's like one of those things
or it's like you know an argument in
this situation like this can be made
okay well they just he just kind of
emptied their bank account on this and
let's see how it pans out cuz this is a
do or die
no that's Microsoft they can do that
again and again and again they I mean
what if in like six months time they
poach five more huge streamers off
twitch yeah for a lot of money and I'm
sure these are obviously we've all
theorized that this this is probably the
kind of money that is like absolute not
that his life wasn't already changed
from money from twitch and all that
stuff this is like you can really sort
of relax for once like he could take
weekends off he could you know take
nights off oh yeah that's a signing
bonus for you yeah it's like he doesn't
he don't no longer has to do the
relentless grind that is live streaming
I mean I imagine someone that plays that
much and enjoys what he does that much
he'll continue to stream many many many
hours but it does give you peace of mind
that you're no longer just strictly
performance-based you know yeah that's
the really hard thing about live
streaming is that if you're not there
well well then we'll find someone else
to watch that's live yeah it's it's
similar to being a content creator on
YouTube but in in a much more like hyper
sense so like if you follow a youtuber
and they don't post for a month right
that's pretty irreparable damage for
them because you trust their schedule
you rely on them you know this is
provided they make weekly videos or
multi multiple videos a week and if they
disappear off of YouTube for a month
they come back
usually they see that damage for
a long time for twitch it's like a week
it's a much smaller amount of time if
you go on vacation or on vacation if you
take more than a couple days off in a
row I mean and it's not it's not seeing
like oh this minute this many less
people are watching me or I feel like
people are mad it's like literally you
see the sub count drop if you take days
off that you know aren't usually off or
if you take extended periods of time off
like a week or two weeks you see that
sub count because the reason people
reefs up and click that button where
they're like I want to share how long
I've been subscribed to this person is
because you're live no one goes to an
offline channel and and initiates the
reset alert and that's what I feel like
cultivates and it's not a twitch thing
or a D live thing or a mixer thing you
know but it cultivates a lot more
competition yeah in the live streaming
space than a YouTube space because I
don't have to share my views with other
people someone could watch my video and
then watch your video and then watch a
Lauren Toyota video and then my own time
a dog YouTube channel because that
person can like multiple things and
watch multiple things and I still get
paid as as does the next person but in
live streaming content it's a little
more competitive for eyeballs which I
think you know we've seen a lot of
people talk about how difficult it is to
get seen when you're a small streamer
and how frustrating that is when you
have like two viewers and everyone's
advice is always like you got to just
keep going you have to do it you know if
if you want people to find you you just
got to be live you know and you might
get a host or a rate or something like
anything but none of that's gonna happen
unless your lives yeah and it's very
difficult sometimes or it's not as
enticing I think for people to go on to
a platform like twitch and just look for
somebody I know there's people that do
it but to look for somebody that has
little to no viewers and just start
getting interested in this person and
the the search capability is a little
bit difficult and you know I wish there
was a training page for clips that was a
little bit easier to navigate so you
could find people and find funny moments
and find funny people or entertaining
things because on YouTube you're just
constantly bombarded with content that
you've never seen before to keep you on
there you
a home page you have the training page
you have your subscription box like just
a never-ending feed of oh well if you
like that you might like this if you
want content there is content to watch
but that's that's Google that's you to
yeah you know and it's just much
different when it comes to a live
situation because like you said the X
amount of people are only free to watch
a stream these hours of the day right
and so if one person is no longer live
then the eyeballs go elsewhere but
that's why you see like for example
Ninja has more YouTube subscribers than
I do and you see a lot of people upload
clips upload highlights upload full
games whatever they want to YouTube
because a lot more people have more time
to watch it at their own pace than they
do to watch it live so those live
viewers are very valuable and I don't
know I just think it's interesting and
it's also just a lot more competitive of
a space than certainly I exist in you
know I mean even though we are on Twitch
it's not our like primary it's not my
job I don't identify as a live streamer
or a twitch streamer which is why I feel
like I can offer thoughts but like my
opinion doesn't really count yeah I
would I would echo that sort of like I
do identify myself as a streamer but not
primarily it's more of a you know it's
one of the things that I do amongst many
but what I honestly I'm excited to
figure out and to see how this pans out
is so twitch has done an amazing job in
my opinion with with optimizing their
platform adding features I mean think
about like a couple years ago on twitch
you know we started like five years ago
on Twitch but the thing about back then
there were no clips there were there
were a whole slew of things that make
live streaming on Twitch easy and fun
and enjoyable for the community and you
there were no gifted subs like anything
like that no twitch prime service on
Twitter who ever came to work and said
hey Amazon Prime twitch Prime we're
putting them together that guy came to
[ __ ] that day he is smart and changed
the whole scope of everything because
twitch Prime is one of the most like
game-changing things that they ever done
but that's like an example
of the many things that twitch has done
over the years to turn their platform
from watch live game play and a person
playing to twitch which is an
all-encompassing like just huge huge
platform right now it's like you need to
be playing video games yeah there was no
IRL there was go on there yeah you can't
do creative and so with that said what I
know little to nothing about mixer I
remember I played I played pub G with a
pub G partner who was streaming like a
million years ago right we started
playing in the pub G partner program and
it was my first experience like even
looking at mixer the interface on mobile
and everything because I had to create
an account if I wanted to look at chat
and I was playing with him so I was like
yeah let's see what his chat says you
know while we're playing and I remember
this was before twitch introduced low
latency low latency for those who don't
know is like is the small amount of time
it takes for the feed to get to the
viewer so they can react in real time
like if I'm if I say something hello
1 2 3 seconds later you see me say hello
and you can respond to it so I'm reading
your response to what I'm doing almost
in real time and for a long time twitch
had this like 15-second delay and that
was just how their platform worked and I
remember back then before twitch had low
latency mixer had low latency and I
remember talking to the streamer and he
was saying one of my favorite things is
the low latency because it really allows
me to communicate and interact with my
audience on a different level and then
twitch was like boom low latency and so
now twitch has it and literally everyone
uses that but aside from that that
little experience I had on mixer I I
don't know what they have to offer
that's that's new and unique and
different and maybe better or whatever
then twitch does but I'm curious as to
see a what what mixer is I'm you know
I'm not investigating for my own
purposes I'm just I'm honestly a
spectator I'm curious
I'm gonna watch a ninja's first mixer
stream right I'm gonna log on and see
what it looks like and I'm curious to
see what they offer
that's different from twitch and what
the chain reaction is there for twitch
to implement maybe new features or
different features or change their
current features to compete to make
themselves more appealing now that
there's so many eyeballs on mixer I
don't know what that that's gonna be but
it's things are gonna happen I mean
twitch is not gonna just sit there and
do nothing
yeah well on the positive side a lot of
I've seen a lot of twitch streamers
especially fortnight streamers that are
pumped at the opportunity to swoop in
and and take some of that viewership for
sure yeah that's a huge opportunity give
me those twitch prime sub some right
here my name's Jared and I play for at
night how's it going y'all you know what
an exciting time that all these eyeballs
are now free because whatever your
audience is like if I were to go off of
youtube you know people have been saying
this to me for years like oh if you guys
are so mad at YouTube why don't you guys
all leave the platform and then they
won't have any but like in theory yeah
that makes sense but I think the one
thing that we learn about YouTube time
and time and time again is that if any
one person or entity leaves no one
actually gives a [ __ ] it is a massive
massive like just huge platform and I'm
not trying to be insensitive like the
people or Peart like anyone you know I'm
saying but like the the thing is it
carries on without someone else being
there you know I'm saying yeah like it
still exists which is it is in the maker
break of twitch I'm talking about
YouTube you know I'm saying yeah if one
if I personally were to be like that's
it I'm fed up
I'm leaving the platform you know I
think people would be like oh you have
all kinds of different actions but at
the end of the day no the whole platform
stuff is very fine are you saying that's
similar to twitch are different no no no
I'm talking about how people in the past
has said everyone should leave for sure
yeah but the fact matters we we love
YouTube we want YouTube to be what we
hope it is like what they we wanted to
have more clarity be more clear and
understand how to make money on the
platform how to use it yeah yeah what's
what's blocked like what
not able to see like why aren't I
getting my subscriptions you know we
want transparency but they really do
have almost a monopoly on video sharing
in in that space and watching it you
know I know Vimeo exists and other video
sharing platforms exist but lady are
sharing for people who want to create
content for a living pretty much like
the monetizable you know whatever right
YouTube is the place to go for that I
love YouTube and we don't want to leave
YouTube but but people in our audience
have for years been like why don't you
guys start your own video platform which
is like unless you're Microsoft or your
Amazon millions it doesn't matter if me
in ten of my YouTube buddies go take our
money and invest it's like it's not a
thing it's not even possible so I think
it is interesting that the competitor
right now is Microsoft yes that is that
is very interesting that it's Microsoft
that runs mixer right because it's like
that is a [ __ ] big boy but that's
like money and infrastructure to
actually make it a viable yes
competitive space yes it's not there
right now they have the ability I agree
I agree it's this it's this ambiguous
powerhouse that's backing this
competitor to a powerhouse of twitch
right you'll like back when vessel came
along right and took a bunch of
youtubers well it took him but you know
bought them out to where they had to
post content first on vessel and then
YouTube that was interesting I don't
think it I don't think it was the same
there wasn't that same like um when that
happened because a someone could in
theory and did post on both platforms
which is not the case for twitch and
mixer it's one or the other both of the
contracts that they signed people to are
exclusive and to whose vessel nobody
knows who they are I mean maybe it's not
exactly it's not Microsoft it was an
interesting concept and it did inject a
little bit of competition in the YouTube
spaces traditionally in the past I guess
YouTube's only competition is twitch a
little bit I guess
and also traditional media you know
there are these people gonna leave to do
television or create their own projects
and leave the platform I don't know you
know but it was an interesting thing
that all of a sudden vessel came around
and was like here's a bunch of money to
post your content exclusively on our
platform first and I don't think it
worked out you know but I don't work at
vessel I don't know how there were
plenty of people willing to take that
upfront paycheck and say you know I
don't really care if your platform lives
or dies give me that check and yeah I
got no problem uploading my content 48
hours there yeah for sure and what even
though Microsoft runs mixer like it is a
possibility where mixer goes okay ninja
okay doc okay I know shroud yeah like
four or five huge creators right they
bring them over they sign their
contracts that give them bonuses all of
a sudden mixer has eyeballs or whatever
it is possible and that's an area where
mixer still has the option or the the
room to [ __ ] up right like they've
they've pulled these big names but now
if they don't deliver with it they're
they're just how you run a platform
right their communication with their
creators their optimization their viewer
friendly features gifting sub stuff like
that like if they don't deliver if they
don't upkeep if they just buy these
streamers out and then they're like okay
they'll deal with it that's a big
problem and that could cause a whole
bunch of different levels of competition
there because then it's like okay this
is what happened when streamer a B and C
jumped ship and made a bunch of money
right then and there but down the line
it really [ __ ] bit them in the ass
right like that's a possibility a world
where they invest a bunch of money and
time and then stop doing that because
they've got these creators and they
think they can just kind of rest on
under contract yeah well yeah and it's
possible that you know anytime you leave
your platform that only a percentage
follow you to wherever you're actually
going and that not as many people will
watch the streamer once they're on the
platform that someone doesn't enjoy so
it not
needs to be optimized for the creator's
sake but it needs to be optimized for
their viewers sake and people say that
they really enjoy the interface of mixer
yeah but I've also read people that on
Twitter that say that they don't they
don't like that interface yeah so if the
community isn't enjoying it you know it
could have different ramifications for
that decision in the future
and another thing right like you know
say twitch comes out with this bomb
feature right I don't know what it is
because I don't work your twitch and I'm
if I said it right now I'd be giving
away a good idea okay no I'm just saying
like what if they you know in six months
time they come out with a really dope
feature to where it is just like all the
streamers on Twitter like [ __ ] yeah
twitch you did it it's like how they did
with Amazon Prime what if they come with
it an Amazon Prime level idea number two
right and it's one of those things where
only twitch could do it because of
Amazon owning them or whatever reason
right it wasn't like a a dupe duplicate
a bull that's not a word I could they
can't copy it pretty much it's not
something that mixer can just be like
hey I want to copy that
proprietary proprietary thank you and
then like what does that mean for the
streamers on mixer that right there like
damn right they're looking over there to
their periphery and seeing all this
really really cool [ __ ] going on and
maybe a lot of money being made or maybe
it's giving the streamers different
opportunities or supporting the
streamers in a different way that
they've ever been supported I mean I'm
talking like you know we're like
Internet creators right you sign a
little contract so that you don't stream
on a competing platform you go live you
collect your paycheck there's that but
what if twitch is like hey we want to
give you like I don't know some sort of
crazy support that a big corporation
that you would work for would give you I
don't know what kind of benefits those
would be but what if they came out with
something like that right and then make
sure your streamers like [ __ ] like we're
just getting paid dollars or like I
don't know you don't I mean like it's
this ambiguous like possibility that
could exist in the near future if big
moves are made on
either side but yeah I don't know I mean
there's all types of hypothetical
situations but I I just think it's
interesting because we've seen it happen
both ways a big creator leaves and it's
really great for them or a big creator
leaves and the platform is so fine and
the creator is worse off you know only
time will tell and I think every
platform is different every technology
is different you know the way that
Instagram sort of poached everything
that was wonderful about snapchat and
snapchat sort of dug its own grave like
it could go either way and then the
world so I know that's a great that's a
great analogy or an example right like I
don't think anyone really thought I mean
we all thought that was so fun and great
I never saw that coming and I know a lot
of people like to claim that they saw
coming and maybe they did maybe they
they knew about snapchats like behind
the scenes people and their CEO and what
was gonna happen and maybe they did
whatever but for me I was like I was so
on board snapchat I was like oh you guys
remember I suppose it all [ __ ] time
and when Instagram stories came out I
was one of the last people to finally
give in and be like okay fine I'll do it
but now there's literally no reason for
me to be consistently posting on
snapchat on instagram stories unless
it's how I was like here's money do you
know I mean and even then it's such an
unauthorized late to the game with these
features platform I mean yeah Instagram
ripped a lot of their [ __ ] but Instagram
also made it better and kind of left
snapchat in the dust but it is a good
example of what could happen mm-hmm I
mean it's not apples to apples it's more
like apples to lemons but what's a lemon
what's an apple twitches a lemon and
instagrams an apple no I'm just saying
it's not it's not an example of a
creator leaving a platform for another
platform it's it's a no but no but what
I'm saying right is mixer has big names
now and if they start poaching these
ideas as well then it's like who knows
do you know any mean like it could yeah
it could pose a similar situation as all
I'm saying mmm-hmm so how does it work
on make sure uni what what I don't know
all I know is that I I play Elder
Scrolls on Xbox so I always feel like do
you want to watch mix it and
like no [ __ ] I'm already on Xbox I got
[ __ ] to do and I want to stay here and
watch stuff on my xbox I want to play
games on my xbox remember when remember
the Xbox twitch app where you can stream
from your xbox yes I do remember that
good times you sound like you want to
talk more about that No
well so the thing is about mixer is that
I know they clearly it's not like this
came out of nowhere like they clearly
have been taking twitch streamers or
offering money to twitch streamers to
come stream on mixer like that's been a
thing so they've tested what you know if
we have a person that has X amount of
years on twitch and we ask them to come
to mixer you know what do those numbers
look like like is this is this worth our
money they've done this on smaller
scales before they decided to you know
give ninja a competitive offer mm-hm so
it's interesting it must be I'm guessing
at least proving to be somewhat fruitful
for them on the smaller streamers that
they have decided to do that too
otherwise they wouldn't continue it nor
would they make AB giant investment in
ninja you know mm-hmm yeah but I mean at
the end of the day when there's more
competition really everybody wins
I that was my first thought when I went
I really didn't read the news on Twitter
Chris called me yeah he was like ninja
move to make sure and I was like good
morning Chris how are you I was just
getting out of the training I was like
we gotta talk about this but yeah that
was my first thought is like that's
great for us yeah it's great for ninja
it's great for twitch streamers it's
great for mixer like it makes people
interesting like if you like say you're
a you know someone that loves to watch
fortnight's dreams yeah and maybe twitch
isn't your favorite maybe it's not your
favorite on mobile or your favorite on
your desktop or whatever you're watching
it on whatever kind of person you are
wherever in the world you are for
whatever reason and mixer was easier for
you now you have someone that you could
watch on mixer it's it's competition is
good it's really good it's really good
because the moment people start
preferring one thing about one platform
the other platforms gonna go we got to
get good yeah we got to make it better
and I know that people have complained
in the past about twitchett handling
their Community Guidelines and you know
the same with YouTube a lot it's hard to
write a blanket set of rules that apply
to everyone all the time and enforce
them the same all the time because life
and the world is very grey it's very
hard to just black and white everything
but I understand people's frustrations
and that gives people a competitive way
to say I'm out you sure one of the
things that I'm curious to see the
difference of you know because a lot of
one of the things that people have
complain about a lot with twitches ads
and the way they work mainly if you
don't have turbo or Prime something I
signed up for a long time ago so I don't
have ads but if you don't have that if
you're just a viewer without that you
click on a stream you immediately get an
ad every single time no matter what
which means if your channel that you're
watching raids another channel or hosts
another channel sends their audience to
see another Channel
all of the audience that's swarming the
new channel to support them and say hey
we're rating you all have to watch an ad
right and you don't get to see their
reaction I mean that's a big problem
that's a that's a problem that's almost
rendering one of your coolest features
useless in some certain situations so I
would love to know how mixer does their
ads and what their host situation looks
like can you host people and makes it
like things like that
because that is one thing that a lot of
people for a long time have said hey
twitch improve this please improve this
because we want to send our audience to
other streams but if they're just gonna
get an ad and no one's gonna stay so
especially when it comes to like say you
have like a a stream with 50 viewers and
you're like let's do it we can raid
someone you know I mean it's exciting
the first time you have enough people to
raid someone yeah and then they all get
an ad and you're like [ __ ] so that's
just an example but obviously it'll be
interesting to see and I I personally
haven't seen a lot of people being like
[ __ ] you ninja like nothing like I
haven't seen any of that I've seen
people being like at least gracious and
saying good for you I hope that's a good
fat check like you deserve it they go go
do whatever decision you want to make no
like it's a it's a competitive move and
you know there's a lot of people that
wouldn't
you know that kind of money and go take
it and see what happens but I think
it'll be interesting to watch what
happens and its ramifications throughout
the rest of the live-streaming gaming
community you know what that means for
people or know what opportunities it
opens up or or not yeah and I mean I and
also at the end of the day doesn't
affect me right now right now it doesn't
I'm just gonna play video games
regardless so keep gaming know what I'm
saying yeah and I mean listen I've met
ninja once in person we've met him once
at the Dillon party at twitchcon and he
was very nice and I do I wish him the
best I think it's very exciting I think
there's a congrats in order so congrats
and sure you know and it's it's one of
those things that absolutely is changing
the way things are going to go from now
on is a big big blip timeline for sure
and I've always said that about anybody
on YouTube is like if somebody's getting
an opportunity to use somebody's making
a ton of money like somebody's doing
something crazy you'll get all kinds of
different opinions about why people
think that you're greedy or wrong or
something or whatever yeah but the fact
of the matter is that every time that
someone does something like that it
opens up doors for other people so good
or bad for ninja personally I think it's
good for everyone like in the future
definitely gonna make waves for sure for
a long time yeah you know what else
makes waves good tacos
no okay tacos can be the life of the
party if you allow them to be but who
wants to make tacos not me not you you
want to order tacos from your favorite
local taco joint what is that I don't
know I don't live in your house but you
know what it is it's that authentic
beautiful you walk in you get the aroma
stop I'm so hungry stop it it's called
talk about now I'm just kidding it's
probably whatever I don't know whatever
restaurant talk about for some people
but other people it's way different and
better and I don't know whatever it is
you can get an on post mates probably
the way to find out though is to
download the post mates out and not cook
anything in your kitchen
use code Jenna Julian to get $100 off
free delivery credits me for seven days
of using the app and then you have
someone else very kindly bring that food
in a bag to your house or place of work
or bench at the park whatever the [ __ ]
you are young they will bring you food
and then you take it out of the bag and
you eat it yourself you share with the
party you put it in Tupperware
containers say you cooked it the options
here are limitless and they all start
with post mates so get post needs right
now check it out okay use coach and
Julian let us not you like it send
pictures of food we like pictures of
food enjoy your food hopefully your
guests enjoy your food if you lied to
your guests about cooking it hopefully
your friendship doesn't suffer from it
the end thank you post mates
thank you both hey no don't do don't
he's sleeping I kissed him in his leg
moved anyways I hope you guys understand
what we're trying to say I don't if we
didn't say anything perfectly correct
we're just talking yeah this I mean we
learned about this just a handful of
hours ago so we haven't had like days to
sit on it before and we don't have any
information that might have come out
over the weekend yeah we have more
recording this on Thursday yeah we
haven't watched the Phil DeFranco show
on it right that's the real information
that we're gonna get I'm gonna get that
tomorrow morning I can't wait punch me
in the throat Phil please with this
information okay we have a game that
we're gonna play up someone went live
and my phone is automatically going to
it Jason it's corn bone himselves
birthday corn bone has Bo season y'all
so we're gonna play a quick game of
Florida headlines cork Florida man or
did it happen in Florida no no no no no
we don't call it Florida man or not oh
the man Oh nah Episode one beacon all
right so I have 12 fake headlines and 12
real headlines that have happened in the
last year and I have to get we're not in
last year and ever all in the last year
for the real ones I think are within a
year hopefully I think I can don't fully
hey don't question my sources okay hi
fact-checked here we go
are we ready so play
Flo - man enough though - man on na
Florida man killed ex girlfriend while
trying to get rid of the devil that was
a dark one to start on I think that
that's a real headline correct that one
was real wait do you have any context
for these you just have the title the
context is that happened in Florida what
I didn't what I'm not gonna research
these articles I look at headlines come
on I want to know lineal don't read the
article I just look at the headline I'm
a millennial - when I relentlessly read
every word of the article is a joke but
I'm not gonna read these articles pretty
much he probably killed his ex because
he thought she was the devil because he
was on drugs or something oh yeah I mean
99% of these probably include drugs okay
hey I needed a little bit the story it's
so uncomplete there is literally not
anything else - no it's drugs
Plus that equals the real story Florida
man drinks four gallons of water
claiming to be Aquaman hospitalized
Julian that is a Julian story how did
you know she started laughing be
specific
four gallons of water am Aquaman you
would die nice guy Thanks you can drink
too much water what's that called are
you drink too much water being Aquaman
no there's a word Florida woman shocked
and hospitalized after being caught on
camera walking through neighborhood
cutting neighborhoods power lines power
lines are up high
Florida crazy why would you say that
that one's fake got it correct I'm doing
really well guys don't worry how would
she be she would need a ladder what she
got scissors cuz you can't cut him with
scissors she need like those big shears
okay
hey pen what I don't you okay you saw
through it
Congrats moving on Pensacola couple
caught running scam driving people
through carwash claiming it was Disney
World
okay you know what
I here's what here's I'm gonna get there
I'm gonna say that this is real because
I don't think you know where Pensacola
is I don't but it's fake let's go I
wrote that one that's a good one but I
feel like people could say we're a taxi
to Disneyland and then just driving
through the carwash and be like all
right get out yeah that's that's what
they did they were in that scam
Blake you made that I was fake that's a
good one
Florida man who drove Ferrari into water
said Jesus told him to that has to be
fake is it real I have to be fake real
but that's what clique beat come on yeah
rest of the story okay is this gonna be
Jenna demanding more facts or floda oh
nah
come on I mean anyone can google these I
literally I didn't have time babe to
read the details of these people doing
these things okay
a man actually punted a rabid coyote in
Kissimmee so many things going on there
I'm missing it's real it is real yes
rabid coyote got punted I feel like they
just they maybe they just have a little
more Flair when it comes to titling game
I think they might these also could all
be fake cuz I got him off of a list that
said top Florida headlines that are real
what we're making an entertaining
podcast here okay fact-checking on news
station okay why why wouldn't he just
two hundred and 295 stolen iPhones found
in Florida woman's home she claims they
were a gift
that's real yes
295 iPhones were a gift
she's like yeah I got a patreon you know
people just let me give she's got feet
pics on patreon Prosecco really like my
feet Florida man arrested for the man
arrested for trying to fire employees at
a target he did not work at okay that's
the Julian 1 that is the Julian that's
fake that's fake that is something that
came right out of your brain
yeah the old gold mine I know your brain
I live in there like most of the time ok
you like it in there rattlesnake
carrying Florida man claims to be agent
of God okay that's real carry a person
oh no no rattlesnake carrying Florida
man yeah he is a man who is rattlesnake
carrying please wait Seattle snake -
carrying like I am a rattlesnake
carrying man you understand I saw how
you read it I read it exactly how
written again rattlesnake carrying
Florida man claims to be agent of God
okay I can see reclaim to be an agent of
God well you never know I mean maybe the
person who was reporting was on drugs
and heard the snake say that the end
Florida man arrested for pointing his TV
remote at people at a mall and yelling
mute
fake [ __ ] I was too obvious that was
fake yeah it's clique for living on the
plot of clique Florida man arrested with
cocaine stuffed Lunchables is real
why is Lunchables why put cocaine and
food is what I want to know it's trying
to hide it oh I get that that's actually
I feel like Lunchables would be a sick
spot to hide some coke oh my god
I'm just thinking in the mind of a
Florida man I've never eaten a lunchable
or done cocaine one of those things is a
lie I see a lot of Lunchables when I was
a kid I would I would skip the fruit
some of them had fruit in them right is
the little dessert
I never had one well there was one that
had like I I just remember taking the
crackers in the cheese and the meat is
that all that was in there
yeah pretty much all then I like to wear
ones that are more than that but yeah
when I was a kid it was just that
Lunchables for dogs okay hear me out
sure you can't use their hands here yeah
okay listen it's a it's a paw peelable
wrapper so Paul can just take off the
wrapper clean okay it's dog food but
it's human grade and the plastic is
edible too so they could just eat the
whole thing
it's terrible it's got a lot of calories
and it's got a lot of chemicals but it's
pass okay I would do good call Florida
man breaks into Florida man breaks into
store flips off security camera reel
that's real yeah sounds about right
imagine it's probably just like a local
store like he knew the guy that owned it
and knew he was gonna get caught anyways
Florida Florida restaurant shut down
after serving vegan customer bowl of
dirt I think that's real that's fake and
that would suck I'd be funny though
imagine if you risk like your your
restaurants food rating to get at
someone yeah but it wouldn't be the
person that runs the restaurant it's
just like some waiter that's had it yeah
100%
hmm Florida man steals blimp gets
arrested said his mom told him to real
fake boom and mom said to do it
I just was stealing a blimp how do you
even get in one I don't know but when I
work I worked at a day camp in Boston
you worked at a blimp camp no I worked
at a day camp in foster and hood the
company that makes like ice cream and
stuff yeah promised to fly a blimp
because it was like over it was like on
an island pretty much about you do drive
there but drive to an island I'm sorry
I'm just wondering no it's not no it's
not a blimp camp there's a bridge would
promise to fly a blimp over and drop ice
cream from it realized that it was a
horrible life safety concerns
knocking kids out with ice cream bar job
in ice cream that's horrible that's
that's like a bad promise to not keep
that's like Scott's tots
okay I don't know what that is yeah
you'll learn something
someday baby why am I always getting all
fist rolls Florida man accused of
throwing pancake batter at woman how do
you real that's real how do you even
throw batter it's like a pseudo liquid
West Palm Beach lemonade stand shut down
meth found in the lemonade true-false I
made it up damn nothing but net baby get
at me
good one Florida Church claims the Sun
is gay Falls that is that came from my
brain I came from my brain thank you
very much
please stop
squirrel attacks Florida man rodent was
raised by neighbor squirrel runs into
what Wow no Kermit was crying at me okay
squirrel attacks Florida man mm-hmm the
squirrel or rodent yep was raised by the
neighbor true true yeah lots of people
rescue squirrels
is the squirrel rodent I think so I
guess it is because of this headline
Kermit's crying Florida man legally
marries mannequin true-false damn it
can you legally marry mannequin in the
United States somebody has had to have
tried it some body good
Florida man shoved woman because he
wanted to eat egg rolls in her house
okay that's that sounds like an Julianne
title is real is something that happened
in Florida eat egg rolls it's like the
Kermit of neighbors yeah I'm gonna break
in and eat egg rolls in your house I
don't want to eat a mine I want yours in
your house Florida man throws pizza
slice at mom during argument true true
same thing with the guy that throws
batter they're eating they're eating and
getting in an argument and they just
throw whatever isn't closest to them
Florida man dances through DUI sobriety
tests true that is true his [ __ ] sick
I'm guessing he failed my guy put on a
show all I gotta say
not funny Florida man pulled over
driving washing machine with ATV wheels
attached true-false damn it that was the
last one washing it could happen it
makes the sound of a car mm-hmm and if
some really smart or on drugs guy and
for a knew how to use the energy and
power from the washing machine to power
the wheels amazing easy just sit on top
of a rock isn't there a YouTube channel
where the guy just puts like a cinder
block in washing machines until it like
completely falls apart yeah I like
destroys the whole machine it's pretty
great that's his whole channel many of
his videos what are we doing you buy a
washing machine every single time we
made a video it's very cost effective
mm-hmm and it's probably not Deema I'm
pretty sure that they're old and like
not really that functional to begin with
but yeah
hey he could be a young creator I know
you meant the washing machines about
sick Madhu yeah what's wrong with you I
don't know I'm hyper I had a lot of
caffeine today which you could too
now I'm not doing that again are you all
right I'm fine I'm fine
he just needs a hug yeah he had a really
rough day this week guys we took him to
the beach gave him food can let him run
around on set beach with other dogs was
really traumatizing hmm he cried the
whole time yeah poor guy send him some
love
he's really sad from his day at the
beach in grete well anyway that was
flowing a headline or nah flown to
Mindanao de menor nah you wrote some
good ones you really did trick me yeah I
think there's a learning curve to it I
need to find it you know what there's a
relationship between the fake and the
real ones right they affect each other
because it's what you're primed to
mm-hmm so I need to keep that in mind
just like Florida man keeps drugs this
time I want to know the stories if
they're real if you want I can get a
little blurb for each one like the first
couple of sentences or something fine
would that make you happy yeah I need to
know the story
yeah okay they lived happily ever after
and all those stories no no that's true
see I'm telling the story now I could be
making it up all right well thank you
guys for listening and hanging out I'm
not talking to you but thank you as well
thank you guys for hanging out for
another podcast we'll be back next week
to talk about more things but we'll be
live on twitch twitch remember we're on
twitch so we'll see you guys there
throughout the week and I hope you guys
have a wonderful week see on the next
one and goodbye
[Music]